[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zu sein ließ
welt heute gibt es ein rezept für den
advent zum beispiel oder einfach so für
die winterzeit ihr habt nämlich gesagt
er würde gerne ein rezept sehen was
wirklich ein verwendet zubereitung ist
was man aber gerne mal an so einem
adventssonntag zum beispiel zubereiten
kann
also gibt es hier einen adventskranz
bestehend aus 24 cupcakes wirklich auch
eine große menge ihr könnt natürlich
auch wenn ihr jetzt nicht so eine große
menge oder nicht so viele zu hause seit
mit mini cup cakes arbeiten und dann
eben einfach die hälfte das rezept
machen und lernen ganz zu brechen
ich finde das ganze sieht ziemlich süß
aus und vor allem auch gerade für ein
kuchenbuffet perfekt denn man nimmt sich
im café queck und fertig man braucht
nicht mal ein messer dafür
ich werde jetzt zuerst einmal die
muffins machen das ist ein schoko
muffins gefüllt mit einer richtig
leckeren fruchtigen creme und obendrauf
mit einer tonkabohnen creme ja das
machen wir jetzt für die cupcakes
verwende ich 300 gramm zucker eine prise
salz 320 gramm mehl einen teelöffel
backpulver einen halben teelöffel natron
einen teelöffel zimt 80 gramm
kakaopulver jeweils 300 gramm butter
milch und sonnenblumenöl zwei espresso
und etwas von den extrakt holz bei uns
ein bisschen trubel deswegen sind glaube
ich geführt so 20 gäste im haus
denn egal wir starten jetzt einfach und
ich mach die cupcakes und da könnt ihr
wirklich ganz easy staaten also alle
trockenen zutaten in eine schüssel und
da war ich dann meist so dass ich die
trockenen er in die kleinere schüssel
füllen
dann kurz verbinden
kakaobutter ist natürlich auch trocken
geht auch mit rein das passt heute mit
dem advents kampf dann hast du echt
viele da wirklich ganz ganz viele im
haus ein paar bioshock dahinten der
räumt wieder auf draußen hannover war
bester mann der partei stellte man ohne
den läuft hier nichts
und dann kommen jetzt die flüssigen
zutaten her in die schüssel also die
eier butter milch und öl die
wahrscheinlich die einzige den sondern
drucken glas in seinem glas öl hat ja in
der pfalz ist da nur weinschorle drin
espresso wenn ihr kein espresso wollt
könnt ihr noch einfach weglassen und
stattdessen etwas mehr buttermilch
nehmen und dann noch vanille extrakt
[Musik]
das gebe ich ja noch die trockenen
zutaten dazu und früher alles schön und
dann ist der teig schon fertig und ihr
könnt da wirklich auch abwandlungen
machen das heißt sind weglassen und
andere gewürze mit rein geben
ich finde die mir schon jetzt so ganz
gut was sie auch machen könnt statt
butter milch rotwein zum beispiel
benutzen dann habt ihr wieso ein rotwein
kuchen aber eben als cupcake
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich hier meine muffin form
bereits mit papier förmchen belegt ich
mache jetzt 24 stück damit um einen
großen kranz habe und da kommt jetzt
einfach dateien mit einem eis
funktionäre durch den espresso aus datei
jetzt etwas flüssiger manchmal mache ich
noch etwas fester aber ich finde so
eigentlich schon wirklich ganz gut und
die muffins wirklich auch bis zu drei
viertel voll für dann werden sie nämlich
richtig schön
kommen den muffin sitz in den backofen
oder der zwischenzeit mache ich schon
mal in erfüllung
[Musik]
für die füllung für wendig 300 gramm
himbeeren aus dem tiefkühlfach 30 gramm
bittermandel aroma oder likör drei
orangen eine zimtstange etwas vanille
extrakt 30 gramm zucker eine zitrone und
30 km stärke
ich nehme jetzt zuerst die orangen und
steige ich jetzt nicht genau weiß ob es
vier orangen sind oder nicht und ich die
schale verzehrt kann tue ich jetzt
lieber weg dann kann ich sie trocknen
und für ein potpourri zum beispiel
würzen potpourri zeitzone potpourri
dieses gemischter was man sich vorstellt
und wenn man noch ein heizkörper hat
kann man es zum beispiel auf die heizung
legen unter trocknen lassen
ich werde sie einfach hinter automaten
trocknen und dann hab ich was schön
duftendes in der wohnung das weiße auch
wegschneiden
[Musik]
unternehmen die die orangen in die hand
und könnte die filets ausschneiden hatte
hier rechts und links an dieser haut
entlang
[Musik]
und den rest schön noch ausdrücken damit
wirklich der ganze orangensaft im topf
landes
es kommt hier noch die zitrone rein das
ist eine unbehandelte zitrone dh ich
kann hier die schale mit 14
also ein bisschen vom abrieb und dann
den saft der ganzen krone
[Musik]
jetzt kommen hier einfach alle zutaten
rein nacheinander war wie sieht es
verbindet das ist schön
das ist wirklich schön etwas von xtract
stärke ja jetzt hier noch den zucker
reihen
[Musik]
dann schon mal schön verrühren trotzdem
stange mit dazu und weil ich jetzt die
orangenschale nicht verwendet haben
nämlich ein bisschen orangen passte als
nämlich orangenschale drin und da weiß
ich einfach die darf ich verzehren
[Musik]
jetzt lasse ich die masse hier einfach
auf kochen weil mittel hoher hitze ich
früher auch die ganze zeit damit
wirklich nichts am topfboden antreten
das dürfte jetzt hier auf kochen ich
lasse es jetzt noch etwa eine minute
lang öttl deckt dann den deckel so dass
es ab kühl und dann geht es später
weiter werden die füllung kalt ist und
wenn die muffins kann
für die creme verwende ich 250 gramm
frischkäse 250 gramm quark etwas
sonderbar 60 gramm puderzucker grüne
fasste tonga banker und 400 gramm sahne
ich nehme jetzt zuerst frischkäse und
quark gibt beide zutaten in die schüssel
und wenn ihr keine frischkäse möglich
könnt ihr auch einfach noch charakter zu
nehmen
aber ich finde die kombi ist sehr sehr
lecker dann als vierter puderzucker dazu
etwas tonka
und ich gebe direkt noch grüne verpasste
dazu denn ich möchte einen adventskranz
machen
[Musik]
jetzt die zutaten kurz verrühren
jetzt ließ sich hier langsam die sarah
dazu verbindet sich alles schön und kann
dann die creme mit seiner fahrt steif
schlagen
die creme stelle ich jetzt kurz in den
kühlschrank und hol schon mal die
muffins die sind nämlich auch abgekühlt
jetzt nehmt ihr einfach einen apfel
entkernt sticht hier rein und hüllt
praktisch diesem cup aus nehmt einfach
den deckel hier und bewahrt ihn auf den
setzt sich nämlich gleich nochmal auf
und stehen das ist nämlich jetzt so raus
perfekt machte damals zwei schäden
natürlich
[Musik]
cupcakes ausstechen war noch nicht so
einfach mit dem 4 2 abfällen kerner von
gv schmeißt der tägliche drauf borer
tiefer und nimm die füllung auf den
zweiten teller aber etwas mehr führung
zubereitet denn ich dachte mir als die
soße kommt die füllung auch ganz gut und
jetzt habe ich sie hier in einen
spritzbeutel gefüllt mit ohne lokführer
und die comdirect rhein fast bis zum
rand
ihr könnt natürlich auch einen
gefrierbeutel nehmen drohte eine apfel
zum einfüllen ach ja aber hier ganz
ehrlich das mit der mit dem apfel
entkernt wahnsinniger tipp es ging so
schnell
[Musik]
das wird schön abdecken als wäre nichts
gewesen
das verhindert einfach gleich dass die
creme also die füllung mit der creme in
verbindung kommt und sich das ein
bisschen vermischt das heißt es schützt
so ein bisschen die grüne creme vor der
roten füllung
[Musik]
wenn ihr also auch so einem großen
adventskranz macht dann passen wirklich
perfekt 24 stück auf eine platte und ich
finde dann sieht er auch schön voluminös
aus ihr könnt natürlich auch kleider
machen mit einem blech muffins aber dann
ist dann wirklich relativ finden und
jetzt habe ich hier die creme in einen
spritzbeutel gefüllt mit einer großen
stern thüle und dann fangt ihr einfach
an
in der mitte die müssen jetzt auch gar
nicht hoch werden sondern wirklich
relativ flach dafür aber dicht
aneinander dass man später so gut wie
keine lücke männer zwischen hat
[Musik]
so sieht es jetzt aus schade ich hatte
nicht ganz die lücken gefüllt bekommen
aber letztes mal hat funktioniert alles
funktioniert bei euch vielleicht auch wo
jetzt nehme ich einfach nur ein bisschen
strecke also zuckerperlen und was ich
ganz süß finde hier diese
lebkuchenmännchen das netz ist vor allem
haben ein paar diese kleine zucker
stange und die lebe ich jetzt hier auch
noch drauf ach damit kann ich doch die
lücken doch so ein bisschen ausfüllen
und die können wir jetzt wirklich
dekorieren wie er möchte gerne auch eine
schleife zum beispiel oder rote perle
noch drauf und dann ist der kaffee
advents kann es schon bereits zum
probieren und je nachdem welche deko ihr
benutzt muss darauf achten dass er sie
wirklich erst kurz vor dem verzehr
drauflegt geradezu kapelle zum beispiel
damit sie einfach durch die klinik
schmerzen
[Musik]
morand du darfst probieren sie hier guck
mal so nimmt der vielfach hier eine weg
willst du ganz ohne elegant reinbeißen
oder rein
ich würde ganz und elegant reinbeißen
eigentlich abgelehnten löffel zu essen
das machen wir frauen diese furchtbar
ich kann dir auch halbieren damit du
dich für ein so nervig eigentlich jetzt
schon hier so seiten aufnahmen machen
müssen was macht ein kracher grad
federstrich drittletzten einkommensbasis
die perlen nicht mehr cool boku was ich
da drin eine affäre gelogen haben mit
orange schmeckt sehr gut ausgefallen ist
die füllung noch ein bisschen flüssig
hat die füllung nachhinein reingemacht
oder mit dem apfel entkernt trick und
saucool ist echt überrascht das ist drin
hier flüssig ist wenn ich jetzt die
kamera ausmachen schmeckt dann immer
noch hammer was ist im kern die königin
richtig nach dem cup ko für den ganztag
mit ok ich lachte morath mal in ruhe
noch fertigessen und falls ihr den
adventskranz nach machen wollt dann
schaut gerne auf jolie.de vorbei oder in
einer kostenlosen app da gibt es nämlich
die scala dauert bis zur nächsten wahl
von leckeren altpapier mitgegessen wo
so cool
wahrscheinlich weiß das papier noch mit
papier und seid natürlich sagen cool ich
habe ja noch ein bisschen party gelassen
ich habe es gar nicht gemerkt dass das
papier immer wenn ich sage es knallen
konzentriert war
das ist papier gar nicht gemerkt habe
macht es auf jeden fall nach macht es
wie die knallbonbons rainer könnt ihr
aus papier hessen dagegen ja auch noch
da kann nichts wegschmeißen natürlich
mal
[Musik]